one thing I love about your background
is that you started out like running a
bar in Indiana like you know you run
like you've got like real businesses so
so it's not always been like Mark Cuban
on TV like dispensing checks and advice
broke is a joke man I guess oh when I
moved to Dallas I was living six guys in
a 3-bedroom apartment I was working as a
bartender at night I got a job at a
software store got fired and had no
choice but to start my own business and
you know I was in the same position as
every entrepreneur if I did sell
something I didn't eat and literally my
buddies and I my roommates knife we used
to go to the local grocery store and
we'd wait until midnight when they
marked down the price of chicken and
then we buy just you know the things
that you have to do but yeah I've been
through the fear of thinking my business
isn't going to make it I've been through
the fear of businesses not making it you
know where the experience of business is
not making it so I know what it's like
yeah me too
my first business flopped terribly like
I remember showing up to in my case it
was like the cozy sandwich shop because
they had like free bread samples I'm
just like today because we go to the one
place where you get one beer they had
all the fried mushrooms and peanuts and
all the junk food you can eat and we'd
have our one beer for three dollars and
just eat up so I feel your pain yeah so
we understand what's going on at the
ground level and you know the the tough
thing is like our government doesn't
have the systems in place to really try
and get to the ground level